Probably, but we can wipe it down. Okay. What time is it? Uh-oh. I'm supposed to meet Dr. Barrett at 2.30, but I'll just tell him. Wait. We've just figured out some kinks and are about to start purging period. Can we move our meeting back to 3 p.m. push mark? Maybe even 3.15 push mark?
Uh, you wiped it down? Yeah. Okay, which orientation should we put it in? Just this way. Probably the best. I don't know. I really don't know how fragile graphite is. Barthage may sound like if you dropped it at all. I don't like that at all, but I dropped it. Probably sound good. That is down. Alright, so. Set at 250 degrees. Still recording? Yeah.
All right, green light is on. Turn on pressure control. All right, now we're going to put some vacuum pump and gas wash. Yeah, so and then we'll do it. We're doing it right now before we go temperature at almost. Right now it's only sitting at 30 degrees.
Three washes, well, it's like four washes total. So, yeah, one wash of the whole system at room temperature, then one wash at 250, then two washes at 500 if needed. From the oxygen, accurate. If it's under, if it's like low 20s, he says that's good. Melting pressure. It's kind of nice to know that all of this is for the chamber, and this is for like...
There's like two different, entirely different sections. Yeah. I don't know. Maybe just put a date on that. Now it's going back up with argon. All right, now turn on this guy. Open these a little bit. Wait for cooling water flow to go off. What's that say? I know.
Seems like we could yeah, maybe we can figure out a way to Uh-huh 80 psi. Hey, that's high. Okay, so that's good now generator start. Why is everything a whistle? All right, so once that gets up to 250 degrees I'm gonna press vacuum pump and gas wash again, right? Yeah
No, it all does. It just seems way faster. Yeah, it's because this does five cycles. Sorry, that's what I meant. So five cycles per wash. And only one cycle per wash. Same cycle. The washing cycle, you just press gas wash. So vacuum pump, gas wash. So then it has the ability to suck it out. Melting pressure. Then press. So pressure control keeps this at 150 M bar. I'm going to turn that off so we can suck it out. Okay.
We just watch here now. It's just here. Now we can change this temperature up to 500. It kind of surprises me there's no like manual setting where you can just like a keypad or something. The what, sorry? It surprises me there's no keypad or anything to type in an exact number. All right. Bartos are saying that the furnace system is like a different company and they won't let them like interface with each other.
And so that's why these are separate. That's why it should be really easy to do a single button that does this entire cycle that we're doing. But they can't because this company won't let them access it or something. What? And I don't know what the whole situation is. Maybe it's not like that. There's another reason. That's what you made it sound like. Yeah, I don't know. That's what it sounds like to me, but I don't know what the real situation is. Okay, so that's at 500.
Now we press vacuum pump and gas wash again. These guys? These are the chilled water. Do you feel it? It's like really cold. This too. So see that little white hat hose right there? That's the argon into this tank. I don't know where it comes from this side. He said we could atomize gold and silver in this. Can you imagine atomizing gold?
A bag of powder. Yeah, I wonder what percent you'd actually get back on your wedding ring. Yeah. A 3D printed gold ring? That'd be crazy. Yeah, that's a good question. All right, I'm going to turn off pressure control. Okay, so now pressure control.
okay so it's in low 20s so i think we're good we don't have to do the we don't have to do another purge cycle um so just write down the m bar all right now we can bring this up to 800. is there a reason that you went to remember you went to 850 and then brought it down to 800 um that yeah i can't remember what that was about i think you just like felt like that was a good amount so i guess we'll just have to play with it
it's not like exactly yeah i'm gonna set it to 8 30 and see how that does so we're hoping is that this is gonna mix well this is still recording yep we're hoping this is gonna mix well oh it's starting to glow that'd be sweet i'd invest in that i don't think it's melting just yet though so how many um how long were these uh caps that you made just looks like maybe we don't need to make them so long since
It didn't go hardly in at all, you know? What ordering could explode. I guess we'll see if .17 bar is high enough. He kept turning it down. Oh, hey, it's melting. Oh, it's gone. Definitely not a lot in there. I'm not seeing... Oh, wait. I see something that looks like the powder might be clumped up again.
No, I think it's mixing. Yeah, I think it wasn't there a little bit and then it melted or might be still something. As the induction happens, it mixes it a little bit. Yeah, exactly. It's kind of amazing the heat from the window versus like... Oh, this is like full. Yeah. Okay, so we let that go for about two minutes. And then all hell is going to break loose when we try to get this to atomize properly. Yeah, it might be too much.
So I'm going to bring it to about 90. What's interesting about this is you can't really know what that's set to. So we're going to have to create digital readouts. So we know, okay, this is 90, maybe, you know. It's like 88 to 100 there. Around 90, yeah. All right, so I'm going to do the thing now. Check the plate. What plate is this? Yeah. I'm not going to go to the carpet.
All right, hopefully this goes well. We'll see. Ceiling rod, grinning pressure. Will you turn off the frequency? Hey, look at that. It's totally working. Yep, I think so. Most of it did not get atomized, unfortunately. Okay, so it was definitely too high. It should have been a lot lower, I think. That would have helped a lot. Let's see. The plate needed to be a lot closer to the thing.
So I have more time to run down it. Once I have a ceiling rod. Dinner to stop. And ultrasonic to start. Cooler, yeah. Temperature. Bring this down to 250. Well, we got some. I don't know how much, but definitely some. Yeah? Like, you can see a pile? Oh, good. 250. Okay, now we seem to wait until it's 400 degrees up here. Then we can...
Open this and cool up faster and then we'll clean it It's the the graphite when exposed to oxygen above 400 degrees or above 500 degrees Reacts with oxygen. Okay, and so when it's below 400 or once it's at 400 degrees, it's safe to expose it to oxygen. Kind of interesting, huh? Right, I love it like water dripping on
No, this is leaking so we need to get up we need to tighten that more something Yeah, first atomizer run by ourselves. Whoo pause the video